[Musica]
la cia
bontà dei ragazzi tutto a posto tu stai
bene
tutto sta bene si avvicina adesso vi
lascio parlare si vada prepararti il tuo
cialli a me io devo parlare io sono io
che non sono i servizi perché no si
lascia ad hoc da dopo allora aiuto a
parlare contro possono dare per la
challenge
no perché perché non so conversare molte
persone mi dicono ma tu sei davanti al
computer e quindi se metto in fila due
parole quando parli con qualcuno in
realtà era avere una volta perché ero
talmente timido che sai parlare diventa
difficile quando sei timido introverso
sai sembra sempre che che sei uno snob
invece non è vero perché sono timido
eccetera però you to mi ha aiutato un
sacco di sta roba quindi adesso anche le
molte interviste che tu fai ma anche
quello si va infatti lorenzo lorenzo ha
cominciato qualche anno fa appunto sul
canale youtube to praticamente ti
fermavi mentre giocavi ai videogiochi e
commenta vi questi questi giochi giusto
si beh
ho iniziato a farlo quando i miei amici
non da solo anche perché sono state
stato veramente da rinchiudere prima
sai cos'è sei anni fa parlare a una web
camera era veramente da gente che doveva
essere rinchiusa adesso la persona
normale ma perché ai tempi
io con questi miei amici non sapevo cosa
fare quindi abbiamo iniziato ad aprire
questo canale a commentare videogiochi
in modo diverso da adesso e non c'era
ancora la webcam i nomi di prendeva in
faccia
parlavo di gioco io parlavo sotto
insieme a questi miei amici
poi la cosa nasce cosa ho aperto il mio
canale ho iniziato a farmi vedere
niente oggi sono qua e forse appunto la
sua fortuna è stata essere tra i primi
no perché si sono diversi
sei anni fa beh ci sono tanti ragazzi
molto bravi
solo che ai tempi essendo uno dei primi
sicuramente questa cosa mi ha aiutato
tanto e andata bene
come è cambiata la tua vita quando è
arrivato il successo allora ti devo dire
la verità ci sono diverse cose che sono
cambiate ad esempio sono andato adesso
vivo a milano quindi vivo da solo
insomma un'indipendenza di timidezza
eccetera sono sempre uguale se non
sembra ovviamente sempre timido
incardina sono un po sbloccato a livello
nei rapporti personali però come persona
sono sempre i tuoi fan e come mai chi ti
segue da tanto tempo questo lo stop 6
alla seconda pubblicazione sardi per
favore grazie mi porti libro eccolo qua
da keynes romanzo di anne fa vj che però
ha deciso di firmarlo con il suo nome
vero quindi lorenzo ostuni come mai
questa scelta
l'ho scritto io insieme a jacopo livieri
che uno scrittore di fantascienza e
quindi gran parte del merito va anche a
lui ti dico in realtà non è che è nata
questa questa cosa da una mattina che mi
sono svegliato e ho detto ok
pubblichiamo in libia che scrivo un
romano non è quello pieno non è andata
esattamente così come limiti penso
semplicemente io avevo già scritto in
qualche cosa del genere una bozza di
quella che attualmente the cage era solo
una bozza quindi 23 pagine di trama e
ottenuto sul mio telefono per un anno e
mezzo e poi con la mondadori avendo già
fatto la prima pubblicazione del primo
libro è uscito fuori che potevano
pubblicarla come cosa però andava
ovviamente scritta e in modo
narrativo insomma con una certa capacità
e io li arrivo fino a un certo punto
insomma rientrato e sono entrato jacopo
appena parlato e abbiamo tirato giù di
che ci abbiamo messo un altro anno però
alla fine ce l'abbiamo fatta
allora i tuoi fan ti seguono da tanto ti
vogliono bene e fanno delle domande
pazzesche come i nostri ragazzi questo
io quindi ora io lascerei a loro un po
di spazio per che hanno delle domande da
porti allora cominciamo con il primo eco
elite o mi volevo chiederti se non
avresti fattore c perché lavoro avresti
faccio allora io quando studiavo
studiamo informatica perché mi piaceva
il computer per ogni informatica facevo
schifo
quindi non l'informatico avevo
intenzione di iscrivermi a un'accademia
di montaggio video quindi più o meno
quello che faccio adesso
linus ciò che volevo chiederti come mai
vi siete sciolti con il di share e
gaming alla realtà non ci siamo sciolti
perché io ho continuato a fare video con
loro anche quando ho aperto il mio
canale il fatto che quando io ho aperto
il ctv faceva un video al giorno e fare
un video al giorno mentre studiavo era
un casinò c'è veramente non dormivo
quindi studiare tenere il mio canale era
diventato impossibile quindi io mi sono
staccato perché non avevo proprio più
tempo di seguire ad essere gaming che
loro fanno legami anche loro si colorano
si nicolas palo youtuber ancora ha preso
una pausa lunga molto lunga un anno e
qualcosa è pigro poteva anche io ero ero
quindi lo capisco
nuove sfide ti attendono prima però c'è
la nostra di sfida che ti attende
[Musica]
restano a piedi siamo pronti per la sua
prova
mirko mirko cosa ci porti mirko una
lavagna prendendo spunto allora da the
cage il tuo libro che ha pubblicato la
trama insomma racconta un pochino di
questo ragazzo chiuso in una stanza che
deve superare delle prove e tu dovrai
superare dai quindi che però non mi
avete chiuso in una stanza
no non se lo facciamo ma comunque avrai
tre prove da superare in un tempo
stabilito dai 120 secondi mazzo va bene
la prima consiste nel coniugare un verbo
che fino a fa pensano italiani di fare
come suoneria savini torturate mezzi
perché no la seconda prova invece e
risolvere un indovinello matematico
perfetto allora lì sono a posto e parla
da sé il terzo è un rompicapo
ok va bene però tutte e tre brava camera
va allora ai due minuti di tempo
ok che ti puoi gestire come vuoi per
appunto risolvere tutte e tre le prove
dove tre le prove
ok per dietro ogni foglio è scritta una
prova poi tu potrai girare i fogli
pronti a 120 secondi in totale e
minimale para 32 minuti di tempo da
adesso ai coniuga il seguente verbo al
passato remoto espellere allora la prima
persona singolare del verbo espellere al
passato remoto lorenzo perché cos'è
allora puoi dirlo scriverlo è full punti
non lo so però spero controlleremo dopo
controlleremo seconda prova legge c'è un
bus con sette ragazze ogni ragazzo a 7
zain in ogni zona ci sono sette gatti
triplo 7 ogni gatto grande a sette gatti
piccoli ogni gatta quattro zampe
cosa hai mangiato a cena
no allora la domanda è un'altra in
realtà ci devi dire quante zampe ci sono
quanti piedi ci sono in questo bus un
minuto ora ci devi dire quanti e piedi
14 fosse sei sicuro scrivi la tua
risposta
perché sì stavolta lo ricontrollando è
un 4 fatto ma li sta bene va bene terza
ed ultima prova è un clipper aggiungi
trenino e per ottenere 6 quadrati
allora deve disegnare se vuoi
all'interno di questo disegno altre tre
linee così da ottenere 6 quadrati da
inquadrati ai trenta secondi di tempo
lorenzo c'è una linea che avanza e
quindi non funziona 123 seconda linea
che avanza regia a cioè quella rossa
sulla destra che non può rimanere dicono
attento perché i pochi secondi vale dai
giochi state 123 45 tempo scaduto
[Applauso]
non potete far finta di non averla vista
come allora fosse stato per me avrei non
l'avrei fatta
le prime due erano giù allora è dato
partiamo dall'inizio mirko quinzi c'è
tutto italiano così produrre anche detto
ha retto
bravo hai azzeccato e poi non sei caduto
nel tranello brave
io pensavo invece di fare giusto il solo
questo darò com'era sta roba scusata qui
qui e qui due e questo andava bene
sporca andava bene così che erano 123456
quadrava
by lorenzo senza tono dopo è bravo ti
sei divertito molto bello peccato che il
tuo ma il challenge non è ha superato e
noi l'ho superato il 33 dei difficili
siamo precisi di come gli svizzeri che
tu non avessi superato il challenge
saresti dovuto andare nella nostra
doccia quindi la doccia sottoporti al
gioco finale alta e la world ok ma mi
devo conosciamo tutti si è tenuto dal
fondo
vieni con me gli stivali
era già andata era già pronto lui non
devo fare niente poi questo solo morire
no non morire no cosa fare come houdini
che scappo da qualche parte no è
intrappolato all'interno della base di
ce la posso fare
solitamente da quante linee è formato un
pentagramma loris ai tre possibili
risposte da darmi ci sono cinque linee 6
linee oppure quattro linee poi presente
cosa è un pentagramma
ok 5 tu dici che le linee sono 53 di sì
la teniamo come risposta la teniamo
allora chiediamo a lei se la risposta
corretta parola la doccia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e basta
5 la risposta corretta mar certa
cantieri sono troppe toglie proprio di
musica ti devi interna